[Música]
empezamos nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca esto es lo que
usted necesita saber antes de las
elecciones revisemos la imagen de la
semana
[Música]
en miconi barrett se convirtió en jueza
de la corte suprema de justicia y juró
en el cargo en la casa blanca en la
nominación y elección más rápida de la
historia
barrett de 48 años reemplazó a la
fallecida jueza ruth báder ginsburg
icono de la lucha por la igualdad de
género la elección de barbate inclina la
balanza de la justicia al lado
conservador que tiene una mayoría de
seis contra tres de tendencias liberales
la corte suprema tiene la última palabra
en asuntos clave que definen el futuro
de la nación como el aborto e incluso en
una eventual disputa de elección puede
decidir quién es el presidente
[Música]
vamos a washington para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda
viena el covent 19 marcó esta campaña es
este el asunto que más les importa a los
votantes estadounidenses
bueno definitivamente es el tema más
importante de esta campaña el tema
generalmente en las elecciones más
importantes la economía pero esta
pandemia ha tenido un impacto muy
importante en la economía estadounidense
no solo porque hay más de 20 millones de
personas que solicitaron subsidios al
desempleo también porque muchas
compañías importantes y estructurales de
la economía de los eeuu como las
automotrices las aerolíneas están
viviendo una situación muy grave a esto
se le suma también el manejo que dio el
presidente de donald trump a la pandemia
que afectó considerablemente a minorías
como las personas afroamericanas latinos
al no tener acceso a seguro en salud y
otros beneficios del estado y
definitivamente el que eeuu tengan mayor
número de personas muertas por este
vídeo y de contagio también hacer que
este sea el tema más importante
y ahora y sin importar si ganaba y de no
ganar trump sería el presidente más
longevo de la historia del país esto
moviliza de alguna manera a los votantes
digamos que lo que está movilizando a
los votantes ahora es cuál de estos dos
candidatos que tienen una diferencia
mínima de edad puede llevar a eeuu a
salir de esta crisis que ha impactado
debido a la pandemia cuál de los dos
puede ejecutar una estrategia importante
en los eeuu pero otro de los temas que
más llama la atención a los votantes
definitivamente en el caso de los
demócratas es la experiencia que tuvo
bailén al interior del congreso como
vicepresidente y en el caso de donald
trump que no tiene mucha experiencia que
es un outsider es decir que sale de la
clase política tradicional pero kamala
harris ha sido esa fórmula que le ha
inyectado digamos más entusiasmo a la
campaña de vaivén sobre todo entre los
votantes jóvenes
bueno y otro asunto es en esta campaña
que ha sido muy importante es el número
récord de votación temprana que motiva
estas cifras sin precedentes
uno de los temas que están motivando más
estas largas vidas que hemos visto de
votantes son los obstáculos que muchos
gobernadores republicanos han colocado
para no facilitar digamos el derecho a
ejercer el voto como en el caso de texas
como en el caso de arizona en el caso de
maryland así que esto ha llevado a que
la gente vote anticipadamente también el
miedo a asistir en persona a votar el
día de las elecciones
hablemos ahora de la rápida denominación
y juramentación de la nueva jueza de la
corte suprema de miconi barrett es una
confirmación sin un solo voto del
partido de la oposición por primera vez
en 150 años qué pasa si hay una elección
disfrutada con esta nueva configuración
de la corte
bueno básicamente esta era una de las
razones por las cuales el presidente de
una acción tenía nominará para ver de
una manera es rápida y también
confirmarla por parte del senado y es
que en el caso de que se registre un
panorama similar al que ocurrió entre
bush y al gore básicamente si se exige
un reconteo pero no hay una digamos
clara imagen de quién será el presidente
tendría que ser la corte suprema en la
que decidiría y la balanza está el día
de hoy a seis miembros conservadores que
hacen parte del tribunal supremo y tres
liberales y ellos estos miembros serían
los que tendrían la decisión definitiva
sobre quién sería el presidente de los
eeuu en caso hipotético de que se
presentará de nuevo este panorama
es el análisis de diana castañeda
corresponsal de france 24 en washington
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
especial de aquí américa camino a la
casa blanca recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho del coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]